[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
[ضحك]
يا حب
واشبكي
ان
لن
تقل قلبك حلما
ساته نائوا به
[موسيقى]
يوم مهما
بالاحلام
ساتاتي بها
[موسيقى]
يا
[تصفيق]
الاغنيه اللي جايه كلنا نعرفها فهستناكم
تغنوا
[موسيقى]
دينا
سلامه
سلمى يا سلام رحنا
مع بعض اخر مره
سلمى يا سلامه روح
سلمى يا سلامه روحنا وجينا بسلامه
[تصفيق]
مساء الخير عليكم
احنا قلنا طاقه بقى شويه مساء الخير عليكم
شكرا قوي يا هريدي على الانشداكشن الجميله
دي انا اسمي داليا فريد وانا بالفعل
درست علوم علوم سياسيه في الجامعه
الامريكيه في الاول بعد كده مسرح غنائي في
ميوزك ودلوقتي بعمل ميوزك
بس قبل ما اتكلم عن سيكولوجيه الموسيقى
وليه الموسيقى قويه ومهمه عايزه اسال سؤال
للجمهور مين فاكر هو اكل ايه بالظبط
الجمعه اللي فاتت زي النهارده كده حد فاكر
بالظبط هو اكل ايه اليوم ده
تقريبا ولا حد يعني طيب لو قلت
اغنيه ماما زمانها جايه
حلوه قوي
ما بين سقفوا لنفسكم ان انتم فاكرين
الاغنيه ههه
الحقيقه احنا ممكن نبقى مش فاكرين حاجات
حصلت في حياتنا امبارح حتى اكلنا امبارح
ايه حصل تفاصيل حياتنا بس فاكرين اغنيه
تقريبا انتوا جيل التسعينات لسه ولا
الفينات يعني مش هكبر نفسي قوي
فاكرين اغنيه ممكن ماما تكون علمتها لكم
من على الاقل 15 سنه
ده بسبب حاجه اسمها الهيبوكامبلز في مخنا
في مكان في مخنا اسمه الهيبو كامبس ده
مسؤول عن تخزين الذكريات الحياه ان
الموسيقى بتفعل المنطقه دي في المخ جامد
جدا جدا وعشان كده احنا فاكرين حاجات
كتيره قوي زي زمانها جايه واغاني زيها
كتير
سؤال تاني مين بيستخدم المزيكا في حياته
ان هو مثلا
للطاقه الايجابيه الصبح مثلا هو بيصحى من
النوم وهو بيلبس وهو بيعمل رياضه المزيكا
بتحفزه في اي حد بيعمل كده
تقريبا كلنا يعني انا وكريم جوزي بنحب
نسمع مزيكا الصبح لما بنبقى بطه بلدي
الصبح بنحط مزيكا مسرحيه اسمها وبنلاقي
نفسنا قادرين ان احنا اكثر وسؤال ثاني مين
بقى المزيكا جزء من حياته الرومانسيه
وبدون احراج جزء من المحن والرومانسيه
والعياط
ايوه في حد رافع الايضتين
المزيكا عندها قدره رهيبه ان مش بس تاثر
على
حياتنا العاطفيه بشكل
انوجاتيك وفيه طاقه بس ايضا حياتنا
العاطفيه العميقه واللي لها دعوه
باحاسيسنا اللي جوا قوي وده لان المزيكا
برده بتفعل منطقه في المخ اسمها الاميج
داله
اللي مسؤوله عن العاطفه
مش بس كده هي المزيكا بتفاعل تقريبا كل
المخ لان المزيكا من الانشطه القليله جدا
جدا
فيها بيصحى جزء اليمين من مخنا والجزء
الشمال واللي عرف ده استخدم المزيكا جامد
جدا في حاجات مختلفه زي التعليم عندنا
مستر سوزوكي سوزوكي ماتت في اليابان مستر
سوزوكي هو مش العربيات هو مستر سوزوكي ده
كان يعني هو زي محمد عندنا كده سوزوكي
عندهم في اليابان يعني هو بيعزف كمنجه
والف طريقه لتعليم العيال الموسيقى من
وهما عندهم ثلاث سنين خلت الاطفال دي
عندهم تناسق اكبر بين العضلي
ذهني عندهم قابليه للانضباط عندهم ذكاء
اجتماعي كل ده الموسيقى وتعليم الموسيقى
في الصغر ممكن ان هو يعملوا للاطفال في في
الحته التعليميه ايضا بما ان المزيكا
بتفرق قوي قوي في الذاكره
في ذاكرتنا زي ما شف نا ماما زمانها جايه
الموسيقى استخدمت استخدمت كثير قوي في
الناحيه العلاجيه ومستشفيات كتير جدا في
العالم كله بتعالج امراض
من خلال الموسيقى
وطبعا بما ان زي اي حاجه قويه جدا الناس
اللي بتكتشف قوتها بتستخدمها لاهدافها زي
مثلا
الاعلانات والبيزنس هتلاقي ان معظم
الحاجات اللي بتحاول تتباع لكم بتتباع من
خلال موسيقى صح كلنا بنسمع مليون اعلان
والاعلانات هي اللي ايه
بتلزق في مخنا جدا جدا حاجه برضو ابحاث
كثيره مؤخرا اكتشفت انه نوع المزيكا اللي
بنسمعها في اماكن مختلفه بتاثر كتير جدا
بشكل رهيب على السلوك بتاعنا يعني مثلا
انت وانت رايح
فاست فاشن يعني ريتال مثلا رايحه اشتري
توب ولا بنطلون او حاجه في الاماكن اللي
هي اللي فيها الشوبنج الكبيره قوي دي معظم
الوقت بتلاقي المزيكا هي اختيارها مش
عشوائي على فكره بيبقى الاختيار المزيكا
سريع
ليه معظم الوقت ده عشان بيشجع
كتير قوي بيبقى عنده المزيكا السريعه اللي
اسمها سريعه عشان عايز ان انت تشتري بشكل
اندفاعي الحاجات على عكس الكافيهات تلاقي
الكافيه تشيل ميوزك
خالص لان هو بيشجعك تقعد في المكان وترتاح
وتطلب لمون وراه نسكافيه وراه حاجات
فنصيحه مني لكم انكم تركزوا كويس قوي في
المزيكا اللي بتتلعب حواليكم بالذات لو في
في مكان تجاري يعني ايا كان
واخيرا وليس اخيرا لان انا مش هطول عليكم
خالص
انا الدكتور بتاعي في الجامعه اسمه دكتور
مايكل البنشر كتب كتاب اسمه
وفي بيتكلم ازاي ان احنا نغني مع بعض وان
جروب
زينا كده يقف ويغني مع بعض ممكن تخلي
الانسان يحس بطاقه ايجابيه اكثر تنظم
ضربات قلبه تنظم نفسه وفي ابحاث تانيه حتى
اثبتت انه
وان انت تحضر حفلات موسيقى حيه مش في
البيت واحنا قاعدين في السرير بنتفرج على
الموسيقى لا ان انا انزل من البيت واحضر
كونسرت واحضر حفله مع ناس مع جمهور
النشاط ده ممكن ان هو يطول في عمرك ويطول
في عمرك ربنا يديك طوله العمر طبعا
ويحسن من صحه الانسان النفسيه وكمان
البدنيه فايه رايكم نعمل تستيردي
اقفوا بقى كده
الاغنيه دي هعلمها لكم هي اصلا اغنيه
افريقيه بس انا عملتها بالعربي اسمها انا
ماشي وقدامي نور اوكي جاهزين تتعلموا
اغنيه جديده
جاهزين تتعلموا اغنيه جديده معلش انا
مدرسه غناء بردو
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
انا
ماشي وقدامي نور انا ماشي قدامي
[موسيقى]
انا قدام
ى ممكن نمشي واحنا بنقول انا
ماشي
انا ماشي قدامي يموت الجزء التاني ده اوكي
بورت بيقول انا ماشي
انا ماشي
اه وانا ماشي
قدامي نور
انا ماشي
وانا ماشي وقدامي
الاول انا
ماشي
انا ماشي
قدامى
انا ما
[تصفيق]
انا ماشي اللي قدامي
انا ماشي
انا ماشي اه وانا ماشي
قدامي نور انا ماشي انا ماشي
الاقامه ماشي قدامي تتحرك
وا انا
ماشي
قدامي
انا ماشي قدامي
انا ماشي
قدامي انا ماشي وقدامى
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ماشي قدامي
[موسيقى]
انا
مشيت انا ماشي
اه ماشي وقدامي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]